j'ai un joueur de l'om qui réagit un
ancien joueur de l'om qui réagit un très
grand joueur ce n'est pas seulement les
défaites c'est aussi le mépris de la
direction envers les supporters donnent
sony ne respecte ni les supporters ni
l'histoire ni les anciens fois le pauvre
pape diouf
paix à son âme tapie et j'en passe
bernard tapie j'en passe
ils ne font absolument rien pour
protéger leurs joueurs mon pauvre rené
même s'il n'a pas toujours été tendre
avec moi aimer ces gens c'est
l'olympique de marseille force à vous
les copains et bien sûr je suis contre
la violence
on les aura les méchants relais alors
est d'ailleurs plein de gens sur twitter
aussi liquidités qui tu es saadi il
s'interroge embrassades il a dit on
accepte alors misé sur twitter jean
passe sur twitter il ya plein de gens
qui lisent sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'ils disent oui rené on adore mais
c'est pas une raison pour excuser qui
s'est passé cessna mais non mais il faut
des parkas manteaux fabas j'ai dit c'est
pas une raison
samedi dernier il faut condamner mais il
faut qu'il faut poursuivre en justice
saison là ils sont ils sont en rien axe
en garde à vue sont poursuivis ils sont
actuellement déférées
inoki sont poursuivis personnes le
chez-nous personnes à marseille ne
cautionne ce qui s'est passé bien sûr
personne personne voilà j'ai bien sûr
résolu par la violence donc personne que
la gestion du président héros soit
catastrophique tout le monde est
d'accord mais je trouve que les propos
de rené quand même laisse place à une
petite ambiguïté parce que c'est je
condamne mais il y avait quatre
personnes qui sont venues et tout le
monde a suivi non rené c'était une
manifestation violente organisée par
lequel s'est tu parles toit des
supporters bordelais connaît monopole de
marseille
paris pas brillé turcotte mais les deux
skippers landes pas faut juste un coup
de fil je tournerai je suis très
tranquille en 2008 et en 2010 les
associations de supporters des boulogne
boys cette association il ya eu deux
solutions de paris il ya une dissolution
de plein d'associations de supporters
j'ose espérer rené ouais mais s'il est
prouvé nos clients mais où et laisse moi
rire des morales mois fait appareiller
et les soirs je suis ni du racisme
le boulot de photos tout juste fini et
la dernière fois que paris a perdu
contre la finale là le bordel qui a eu à
paris ils ont mis par ya la mer sérieuse
je peux terminer juste maffre à la
désespérée rené que si un jour il était
prouvé que cette manifestation
gravissime a été voulu encourager par
les associations de supporters
marseillaise comme les yankees et les
winners et demandera alors dissolution
vaujourd'hui s'est tu pendant qu'il
existe plus de piscines et spas je fais
là vous êtes trompés car on prend pas
lent